all right so an update
we are about
two days away from
the final deadline
and we just finished all the graphics so
here are all the graphics
it's so fun the intro graphic or the
front book cover chapter one
levels of perception the tree and the
human and the analogy
chapter two c theory in the trajectory
mechanics
chapter three the edge and the sponge
theory and then
chapter four portals and code update
chapter five inclusive stakeholding
and these took me so long to get right
this symbiosis between fungi and
trees took me so long to research to
make sure that was all right
it's so important for inclusive
stakeholding especially since the next
graph is the total job space
and then the ai coach graphic turned out
great
and then the follow-up to that graphic
is visualizing consciousness evolution
and this is where we talk about the
hierarchies and then make a little
remark there about richest person how
enlightened is the richest person
yeah sorting algorithm magic trick still
looking good
switch this out for some cells instead
of
instead of o2 and co2 it's not co2 in
cells
that was its own thing is that i
i had to change the color here because
when you if you have co2
and then you have o2 this
i used to have light blue so i had to go
and change all of them to
that purple because that's the same
oxygen that's
it can't be a different color than co2
and o2 it had to be the same color
and then yeah consciousness calculus of
consciousness the integral and
derivative
and then the dress such an important
metaphysical
enlightening event that we breezed
past and then nine another last bit on
identity and porosity
and this is kind of like the finn
chapter 10 on infinity this is recursion
my little metaphysics and then this is
craziness
this is the infinite symphony
and the designer worlds yeah so you got
the you know
we're grabbing maths towns videos for me
to
i love you guys mass town they do such a
good job on the mandelbrot
fractal zoom but uh
for the chapter videos which i still
have to do
all those little three-minute chapter
videos after i finish
writing in all the like quotes and short
words
so few words i'm going to use but yeah
so from that source point
right there refracts into the
light spectrum and all those little
visibility picture when all those little
pixels are little um
okay universes that bubble off and then
here are some examples of universes you
know this one's
ours ours has this yin yang uh
flux ascension style dynamic james
maxwell and the
uh electromagnetic equations
and then everything's in the not of life
and then
we have this strange attractor that all
eight billion of us are playing in a
symphony towards and then that's at the
god head but
in order to get to the godhead and go
under the recursive function we have to
get through all the fermi filters
asteroids
bombs planetary health unlocking the
code of life
and artificial intelligence and robotics
so
yeah so this was a lot of fun
um let's show you of course gotta show
you the
closing graphic too
boom and that's the back cover
galoro boros yeah so the project was a
ridiculous amount of fun
and i love
all of the brilliant people that i got
to
read and learn from and study along the
way and
distill the most brilliant things it's
just been such a
beautifully intuitive and
just grounding creative
process that so few people get to go
and embark on uh and i was blessed
enough to be able to do so and
it's only the beginning because we have
massive further
the pixar and disney fication
of all of this profundity with
chimps and with the anthology
which tentatively is called superhuman
which is dope
and with all of these
badass influencer interviews where
they're going to be
asked questions about the nature of
reality it's going to be so great
so yeah it's just interesting that
you know the forcing function is really
interesting because
if i if i show you here
um like one of my last
uh distillations so these are all these
are all little uh
evernote um
they're like little evernote windows
basically and
that i have open separately and so a
couple of them are
the most recent distillations one of
them is my influences list one of them's
like
the absolute top top things that i need
to do absolutely right now for the
project
but uh let me show you
i'll show you hop distillation number 17
and then um
so that way you can kind of see like
yeah synthesizing into some of the most
profound things i've learned in my life
into art
you know so i have this little break
down right i love this gates quote about
building the upstream framework and then
slotting the knowledge and information
it's basically what i've been doing this
whole time
understand the deepest patterns
communicate to me live to the world so
i'm not going to include
so this is a chapter one levels of show
every single one of these is broken down
chapter one and then blot chapter two
and then blot
chapter three is here the edge and then
blah
right and so right now i'm totally not
gonna be using
all of it um but
uh but i will probably be using
like these top quotes like trees are
poems that the earth writes upon the sky
khalil gibran
all our wisdom is stored in the trees
santosh kalawar
right so and then the second graphic
with the humans
is the human hlp saunder the realization
that each random pacifier is living a
life as vivid and complex as your own
by john koenig and i actually learned
that
that saunder quote like six years ago or
something
like right so closer to the beginning of
the dictionary obser sorrows and
him publishing all these profound
neologisms but
i'm not going to be using um all of this
stuff
um it's just too much stuff i love helen
keller's quote here life is either
daring adventure or nothing
at all nikola tesla's the energy of a
single thought may determine the motion
of a universe anyway so i have to really
really be selective because i don't want
to have that many words in the project
but you know what's funny you like look
at this and you're like
you know like this is
this is all the stuff you're trying to
condense
like look like like this is eight in
chapter
nine david boehm's quote consciousness
is never static or complete
but is an unending process of movement
and unfoldment
and you know what's so interesting is
that like even here you get to infinity
right the last chapter and like
then you're like wow good he made it all
the way
and then you go and you're like wait
that was just
hlp distillation 17. it's like yeah
this is hlp distillation 16.
i love that good they quote the perfect
educational lecture belongs in the
artist's
sphere of work so but then it's funny
because you come here and you're like
this is all completely different
information for seed theory for the
edge for portals for inclusive
stakeholding
for ai coach
and there's there's this is number 16 so
there's
there's there's 17 distillations
like this and specifically hlp
distillation number two
is the one that i poured
a lot of the last couple months into
like organizing and sorting that one's
really has a lot of stuff in it but
then i have all of these you know all
that
all the evernote files i have 4000
evernote files and so i distilled the
most profound things
into another uh hlp distillation on
google drive and i have 40 of those
files but those aren't as
salient because those are everywhere
from like four years ago three years ago
two years ago
one year ago so those aren't as salient
as like
for example hlp distillation like you
know 16 here
you can see it has the integral and the
derivative of consciousness well
i only uh intuited that
um not that long ago maybe like a couple
months ago or something like that
and um isaac newton is a huge part of
this
project with the refraction of
light into the visible light spectrum
also
the classical mechanics foundation they
set with the laws of motion
because that's all about trajectory
mechanics and seed theory and then
obviously the
calculus with libnice
so
it's crazy that you know
i got pretty much like forty
eight hours left and
there's basically
the images are done and then the words i
have yet to fit
in to the the project and then i have
yet to make
the three-minute video for each
chapter and then i've yet to make the
25-minute total book video
or however long it'll be
and there's 48 hours left so i got a lot
of work to do
but um
there's nothing there's nothing in this
world
there's nothing in this world quite like
locking yourself in a burning building
and being
genius enough to figure out the puzzle
to get yourself out
there's nothing as profound and
important as that
so you gotta shut you gotta set a shot
clock
you gotta work your ass off up until
that shot
clock but then the whole tim urban ted
talk
with the forcing function that
procrastination gives to actually
execute is uh super interesting and
important it's like
super powerful and really
uninvestigated so far but
this is going to be massive i'm so
grateful and pumped
so i love you very much thanks for
sort of watching this breakdown because
i knew that it was going to be important
for me to make this documentation just
you know two days out so that i
you know i have something recalling this
process and so i can share it with
people i'm going to make videos breaking
it down as well when i get to la but
yeah i just moved the the rental car
information into my google drive folder
so that i could more easily
access it but yeah i've been pulling
these down off of the wall
slowly all those little sheets that i
organized up and then i've been pulling
them down over here and slowly
synthesizing
into these so crazy bro
so crazy um
that's it that's it
hella grateful um super grateful for
my mom in the foundation that she's
instilled so that i could take the baton
pass and
go off and do this and my grandma and
uncle and everything that they did and
all my
teachers and influences in my life
leading up to this point
just so profound essen gowenka
and go to mabuddha and theravada
buddhism and
you know invite the vedanta and sri
aurobindo and rupert spyra and bernardo
castro up on
ontology and and metaphysical idealism
and
like everyone from you know vivian ming
five years ago maximize human potential
neuroscience
and ai well you know
to beth and corey beth and court in the
you know
biotechnology
like ron vargas helping me for 18 months
you know power through you know 600 plus
interviews in just those two years
and then or shapira
for bringing me into a
the depths of
silence and consciousness and
cellular immobility experientially
and then alexa my
ex-girlfriend who of three years who
helped also with
example i mean she's the one that she's
the one that helped
with the forcing function of getting me
to learn sketch
i saw her doing it obviously and then
other people like
you know tarangala and
thank you for refusing to edit all the
simulation videos and making me
pushing me to learn how to use premiere
to edit video
because i'm the one that edited all of
our interviews
that weren't live streamed which was a
[ __ ] load that i did on the road
um you know
some of the other you know best friends
growing up max chadliev and
greg harner nick fixo chandler cost
andrew
is he all the homies here but also um
the homies that i met in minneapolis and
i'm still really good friends with like
nicolas over in the bay area
massively influential on my life and
thinking first robotics especially and
then
you know in the bay area with jackson
blazenski
all things applied crypto so so
beautiful and
you know jordan rayne for really reeling
me into that theravada buddhism and
um
and yeah tarangala with his just
incredible artistic eye
and just so much else like andrew karsh
and his push for rich patrons to
actually
you know make a big splash on the world
because he's already doing it with the
sdgs
trying to unlock those trillions of
dollars and you know wayne osborne's
been very
motivational in that sense as well june
yoon with inclusive stakeholding
such a crucial thing i would have never
figured out about
my co-result network's fungal root
networks if it wasn't for
learning about inclusive stakeholding
and then eric weinstein in the portal
so profound and important
i mean all the ancient spiritual
traditions reading to old and new
testament
jordan peterson for his biblical
lectures
and just understanding those stories and
the profundity of
just being the highest possible caliber
of morality
confucius wrote about a lot i've been
studying him loud so a lot as well
i mean i'll show you a little bit of the
influences list
but um this is the influences list
this is where it's at right now but i've
been moving things around
so much it's crazy yeah
so christ buddha going loud so confucius
michelangelo sri rabindo the mother
elfasa tom campbell
with this theory of everything june yoon
inclusive stakeholding suzanne simmered
i put up it
so high up because i [ __ ] love her
man she's the one that did the
radioactive carbon isotope tracing for
uncovering how trees communicate via
those
micro-original networks uh the two-way
resource exchange john smart
transcension hypothesis clear graves
down back chris collins barrow dynamics
ken wilbur
all quadrant all levels pierre tlr de
chardin
john gepster jordan peterson walter
michelle marshmallow experiment
danny cannon kahneman amos tversky eric
weinstein neil degrasse tyson carl sagan
on the science communication front tony
robbins on
inspiring people to peak performance joe
rogan for all that he's done for our
world
and bringing that knowledge out douglas
hofstetter she's
profoundly tunneled hoffman these two
guys have profoundly impacted me
conscious asian theory
charles darwin george hegel of course on
dialectics
emcee asher one of the most profound
artists has ever lived
uh david goggins get past that forty
percent rehearsal it is permanentes
irvine laszlo rupert spyro raw
dentino massaro he's done such a good
job communicating spirituality
carl jung sigmund freud carl rogers
alfred adler victor franco emanuel kahn
david boom john wheeler alan turing
john von neumann a universal constructor
and then this is where we get into
physics
oh my god eric weinstein's quote about
physics
kurt uh jamingo uh asked him
on his theories of everything show like
when did you
escape uh consensus reality and when did
you
like really start taking a theory of
everything seriously and
that's what he said that when i started
taking physics seriously
so oh my gosh i'm only at the beginning
isaac newton michael faraday james
maxwell albert einstein
nikola tesla paul derock nicholas
copernicus thomas stars with burden
genius
hugh ever bryce dewitt erwin
schroedinger werner heisenberg bernard
riemann
please pascal gord ford libnys
clee irwin sydney bernard ben gertzell
paul steemitz
john conway eliezer yukowski i j
good this is crazy yay
curse while mama knew iwan i'm so happy
i know somebody's super indigenous like
mama
and joseph campbell trump pj
so many people will frame linkedin i
mean there's so many people
all right this is a little taste so
because i don't even think i have
version control it'd be interesting if i
had version control on the
influences list this shit's long
there's probably
approaching a thousand people in this
list all hella uncommon people that i've
studied
anyway all right love you very much
thank you hope high level perception
impacts you positively and also that
everything else that we do impacts you
positively brings you great value and
that you achieve all of your goals and
you
investigate consciousness and understand
the nature of reality
love you very much contemplate infinity
peace
you